do you do anything special like to start
the year like it's a new year do you do
anything I I have a thing I don't love
resolutions
me too I set them too high I think I do
the same and then I I feel bad three
four weeks in when you're like oh I'm
back to doing it yeah I don't feel bad
about it but I do feel it I see I did
and then I realized I was like well why
am I doing this you know so yeah I tend
to do a word which is easier and it's a
little bit more of an intention right so
it's not so you pick one word one word
okay so this year is embody which for me
A lot of people are very confused by
this word
yeah it's like the physical element of
it of course you know actually like
being healthier but then the living and
breathing your talk and you know walking
you're talking embodying yeah embodying
yes and embodying how you would like
it's hard I think you did set a really
hard goal there but I feel like it's
depending on what you're saying I guess
you're like come December I'm like I
have embodied nothing
is being it's being still we never do
that yeah well that's the thing is like
the little decisions I make throughout
the day you know trying to make the
small choices better so that you overall
feel better yeah but I have found when I
started doing that you would get to the
end of the year and you would see how
that was sort of like an intention for
your whole year it's in your
subconscious I believe yeah when you set
some kind of intention like that and
it's boring if you don't set any kind of
goal or intention that's boring yeah and
I'm super woo-woo in this way me too yes
so I well I've watched your show you did
a show like is it witches have you said
you did which is yes we did love yes yes
I love it because so you're into all
things like kind of mystical right yeah
have you been like that since you were a
kid always but no one in my family
really was so I was definitely you
either yeah and I like totally believe
in magic like yeah for sure because I've
experienced it I've experienced feeling
like magic that's nice and it is wild
when when you put something out there
and you actually take steps to achieving
something when it happens you definitely
feel magical yeah you don't believe in
it aren't open to it that's true it's
all new kind of like what you believe
you create you know yeah I'm oh that
yeah witches was funny because I I love
that channel I did that role but I was
already Freya in so many ways that's
what I was gonna say did that attract
you to that role because you already
like that kind of stuff yes yes I saw
that and I was like oh this is going to
be fun yep I know your projects girl
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm
[Music]